you want to be a normal teenager I got
news for you you're not normal Doris
who's
Doris uh I
am do you think this is the right place
for him could say that about any place
my brother's dying he hasn't talked in
years I'm so sorry my wife passed away
my dad died when I was three Christ it
ain't a
competition I think I should start
sleeping at Sunco so your brother
doesn't get too lonely he's my child
when he's in pain I'm in pain I'm your
child too what about God sake give me a
break you can come to my house if you
need to place a party my mom won't be
there and you can do whatever you want
oh my God I I have to tell everybody um
but who who are
you everyone says this neighborhood is
scary but like when you're in it it's
like not that
scary thank
you it's really hard to care sick people
sometimes you need a
break I dare need to kiss
doors he could have died and you weren't
here once your brother's gone he's
gone and you will miss taking care of
him you'll miss everything all the good
all the
bad we're going to have fun again you
and
me I'll learn how it be fun
again Doris old lady's name it was my
grandma's name oh she died the day I was
born my God is there any conversation
with you that is not like thoroughly
[Music]
depressing